the glitz Virgo elbow we're headed to  Hollywood join us at the red carpet  premiere Marvel Studios guardians or  galaxies to fly from the dolby theatre  in hollywood this wednesday if all 19  said 9pm eastern 6pm specific i'll be  there close thing with my fellow ginger  tomorrow Krinsky and i'll be there  hooking you up on the marble social  media check it all out at marvel.com /g  OTG evolved to where you can watch the  language carpet show follow our live  blog of the event or check out photos  from the red carpet or you can watch us  live across social media on Marvel's  Twitter Facebook or YouTube pages and  interact with us live using the hashtag  Quixote g ball to commute well we'll see  you wednesday on the red carpet live I'm  Lorraine imran and this is Marvel your  universe  [Music]